welcome back to the man who's sitting to
my right right here country music
recording artist late nights and long
necks which is available next Friday
we're listening a voice right now of the
one time new artist of the year Justin
Moore good to see you sir
good to see you man I'm assuming late
nights and long necks is not like about
midnight at the zoo with giraffes
correct that's not weird it's pretty
self-explanatory
a lot of light nights and long necks
went into writing this album but no it's
funny because we named the album late
nights and long nights because I wrote a
song 1819 years ago that I wanted to put
on an album my entire career and we knew
that it was going to be on this album it
ended up not being on this album after
we named the album late nights and long
necks but we thought it was still
appropriate for this album and my wife
and I long story short my wife and I
have a special affinity for Destin
Florida we have a home down there and
have had for a long time we met down
there and I wrote a lot of my early
music down there and the panhandle of
Florida and so we wrote this entire
album down there not my wife and I but
myself sure and your crew like my crew a
motley crew but you know we just went
locked ourselves in our house drink beer
wrote songs and it was probably the
funnest experience I've had making an
album which I think twelve years into
careers is a mouthful I wouldn't say so
sure and now you've got that right there
I mean that's your table I have
panhandle of Florida that's the heart of
SEC country it is right now it is you
know that's theirs it's yeah it's all
SEC whether it be Alabama or Mississippi
or Arkansas or Florida or you know and
and so I know they hold meetings down
there for SEC stuff sure so we love that
area we spending as much time down there
as we can we primarily are in Arkansas
where I'm from but we spend as much time
down there as we can it's funny as in
the commercial break
justin you you mentioned a conference i
hadn't heard in a while the SWAC mm-hmm
Southwest Conference yeah that's what I
grew up watching sure know where we were
if I'm not mistaken we were one of the
only two or maybe the only non Texas
school in that conference and so we grew
up obviously hating Texas yes sir I did
are you doing because my dad made me
know who grew up hating the Longhorns
yes if I'm not mistaken Chris can you
look this up I think just today this is
you know that the horns down symbol is
now going to be a flag abullah fence for
in in the anti celebration horns down is
now okay so it's been flagged in recent
years as taunting but um you can now
horns dad you're now free to horns down
yes Greg Burks big-12 coordinator of
officials said of a player quickly
flashes horns down for scoring a
touchdown he likely would not be called
for a penalty now prolong displays of
the signal of course geez for decades to
mock the Texas will be penalized so
you're fine if it's directed towards the
player so you grew up hating Texas
Longhorns football or anything Longhorns
obviously I love going and playing in
Texas and I have great friends in Texas
it goes without saying I just don't like
the Longhorns
because if I didn't hate the Longhorns
my dad would whip my tail to this day to
this way he raised me you know and so no
you know we were you know we've had a
rough stretch as of late and in football
but we were kind of for a long stretch
in the Southwest Conference Arkansas was
one of the only teams who could who
could challenge Texas you know they were
so good and and I think they're on the
way up again unfortunately but but yeah
we were it was a pretty good rivalry you
know we
our fair share games against them well
now that's at Justin Moore country music
recording artist here in the rich Ostrow
all that said normally as I mentioned
earlier on the hour you could draw a
line between Arkansas and Dallas Texas
in terms of Jerry and Jimmy and and
Cowboys fandom how do you have a
Steelers hat on your head right now it's
funny because most people are Cowboys
fans
part of it is proximity it's you know
it's four hours from where I live now
and then and then part of it is
obviously the Jerry Jones connection he
was on our only national championship
football team in 64 he was offensive
linemen played for Frank Frank Broyles
and does a lot for the University of
Arkansas and I'm certainly appreciative
I was a huge Cowboys fan when I was kid
loved Jimmy Johnson who was also a
Razorback and for whatever reason I
don't know why this had this effect on a
ten twelve year old kid the way that it
did but you know back when Eggman Irvin
all the Smith all those guys were there
I was huge fan Jerry fired Jimmy and I
don't know why I cared so much as a
child who the coach was but I love Jimmy
Johnson and when he fired Jimmy I said
I'll never root for the Cowboys ever
again no kid and I don't know why that
had such a lasting effect but it did and
so years later I thought I love pro
football but I didn't have a team and I
thought I need to pick a team and I made
great friends with some people from
Pittsburgh my bass players from
Pittsburgh the guy who started my record
labels from Pittsburgh and I thought you
know that's a good organization and they
do things the right way for the most
part I'm not sure about getting rid of a
B and embel but we'll see
and so that's been about 15 years ago
it's been a pretty good run okay so you
didn't but let's just make this because
I was just about to ask the time on here
so for you as a 10 or 11 or 12 year old
to make a stand for the coach yeah and
then to go from the Cowboys to the
Steelers and then dad's a huge Cowboys
fans - okay let's but what I'm saying is
that it would have been a bad
to get off of the triplet bandwagon and
then go on the Neal O'Donnell bandwagon
yeah the one championship that Switzer
brought to the Cowboys would be bad
timing on your so this was after yeah
this was probably 15 years ago something
like that so I've seen maybe two Super
Bowls yeah you said if you're going back
to the Super Bowl 40 win we're better
said farewell but in his hometown of
Detroit and cour was done at that yes
and that's 2000 yes okay I was with that
one and then that was 2005 that one and
then being second one there you go so
the the one that gets the Cardinals yeah
right not the one that they lost in
Dallas to Green Bay we don't speak of
that we don't speak of that one and yeah
look I think it's interesting just and
more here on the Rich Eisen show that
the Steelers this year are going to go
into the season with the rare attitude
of nobody believes in us because in the
past several years the Steelers couldn't
say that because you know a large amount
of fans not just Steelers fans believe
that the Steelers could win yeah right
now people are kind of wondering what's
going on right there I worked for the
Patriots last year so so it works but
it's your day I do think it's it's
obviously warranted that that mindset
because arguably they lost the best
running back and wide receiver in the
league you know that could be argued yes
but they're definitely top two three in
the league each of them you know Smith
Shuster I think is is kind of a stud and
and whiting in my opinion I think they
had a really good draft we drafted your
boy from Michigan you could love Devon
but I liked the Benny Snell pick save so
many people were not high on him for
some reason and I just saw the way that
he dominated his bowl game performance
yeah I he's kind of like that that that
he's a trailer guy yeah he's not got
blazing speed or you know but you
roll them downhill and have a good time
trying to stop yeah it kind of reminds
me of Connor in a sense is there a
little bit of baddest in him you know I
think you'll I think he'll mould well
with with the organization so and then
they got another receiver I forget who
they got but a receiver that I think
it's gonna be pretty good from a smaller
school and I believe in Tomlin
I know Steeler fans like to carp on him
and that it's been all they do and I
don't really understand it he would he
would have another job literally within
sixty I had the opportunity to be with
him at an actual a Country Music Awards
Show
we were sitting next to each other and I
just let him know that I was huge
Steelers fan and and super super nice
guy great guy and I've always been a big
fan so yeah I hear you have Justin Moore
here on the Rich Eisen show and are you
coaching your daughter's basketball team
in softball team okay yeah so is it is
it true then that since you're an
Arkansas fan you brought 40 minutes of
Hell to yours I'll be they'll be a
little aggressive you can only you can
only defend at half-court okay so you're
not full you can't wear half-court trap
at home you know we're getting to move
in the other direction man
so trying to create a three-on-two every
time we can I got to tell you that's how
I one of the biggest breaks I ever got
in my career I was at Northwestern
School of Journalism in a graduate
program and the last few months of the
program was in Washington DC where a
bunch of local stations across the
country that couldn't afford to have a
correspondent in Washington DC used us
the students as their local
correspondents and we did pieces and
they they tear them and it was real real
time experience for us I was the
affiliate that I was affiliated with was
K hog in Fayetteville Fort Smith 40/29 I
think the channel was and I got to do a
piece on the Arkansas Capitol Hill
contingent watching the 40 minutes of
hell Nolan Richardson basketball team
won at all and that piece went national
because it was about you know
when was the first fan and the long and
in the oval office at the time so it was
a good time to be home I mean that 40
minutes out
you know Corliss Williamson and and that
whole team was amazing yeah it was fun
IIIi remember you know obviously when I
was growing up we were we were like Duke
and Michigan State and Kentucky and we
were that we were a top-five perennial
team my a lot of my childhood and to see
the last 15 20 years has been really
difficult so my mom you mentioned my
girls and my coaching they're 13 they're
really into sports in particular
basketball and and they've never seen us
be what I got to see as a kid and so I'm
hopeful that you know Mike Anderson did
a really good job of getting us to a
much better place than we've been over
the last you know decade before he got
there
it really did there were a lot of
problems that people really don't
outside the program don't understand but
I'm really excited about coach Musselman
I haven't met him yet but I think he's
gonna do a really good job and I love
the energy that he brings and and he's
he's already doing things that you know
haven't been done with Arkansas
basketball and a long time she's got
nothing but energy man and we got some
juice he definitely does well what he
did at Nevada was pretty special and
sleep Rios yeah and it was funny that
when I did that piece that night it was
a bunch of let's say well lubricated
Capitol Hill staffers mm-hm watching
this game in a bar and I'm from New York
City completely unfamiliar with the
Arkansas Razorback program other than
having watched them on TV had never
heard the pig sooie chant before in my
entire life and it was unique yeah that
way it was I was exposed to it the first
time like what are these people saying
they explained to me there's a lot of
lions tigers and bears out there they
ain't but one Razorback
that was not how it was described to me
but I completely understand late night
and late nights and longnecks available
Friday July 26 the lead single the ones
that didn't make it back home was
released last October it is great to see
you sir thank you for great so you thank
you so much for having me I really
appreciate any time you want to come on
talk music talk football talk about what
I love talk about releasing 40 minutes
of Hell on some unsuspecting other girls
basketball team I like it yeah a very
good big yeah good to see you yes Justin
Moore at Justin Cole more on both
Twitter and Instagram for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app